depuis le début de la guerre à grande
échelle en Ukraine c'est la toute
première fois qu'il se rend dans les
régions de rerson au sud et Louhansk à
l'est
sur ces images publiées par le Kremlin
Vladimir Poutine vient saluer ses
soldats dans ces deux oblastes que
Moscou occupent aujourd'hui
partiellement le but montrer que le
président russe n'est pas déconnecté de
la réalité du terrain lui qui s'est
beaucoup moins rendu sur le front que
vaut le dimmer Zelenski
il est important pour moi de vous
écouter de connaître votre point de vue
de comparer nos notes
impossible de savoir quand les images
ont été tournées seul indication du
communiqué russe se déplacement de
Vladimir Poutine a eu lieu à l'occasion
de la fête de pâquerodoxe célébrée
dimanche dernier le président russe en a
profité pour remettre aux militaires la
copie du Nico northodoxe à l'effigie du
Sauveur qu'il considère comme leur
protecteur
qui est n'a pas tardé à réagir réponse
sèche d'un conseiller du président c'est
une tournée spéciale de l'auteur de
meurtre de masse dans les territoires
occupés et ravagés pour prendre plaisir
des crimes commis par les forces russes
des crimes qui valent aujourd'hui à
Vladimir Poutine d'être visé par un
mandat d'arrêt international ce qui va
de fait limiter ses déplacements hors de
Russie et des territoires qu'elle
contrôle